last gentlemen uh getting to shoot an
international travel show that we call
cone without borders has been
one of the absolute highlights of my
career i love it
uh i really do love it it's also been a
great way for me to hide my money in
banks
all around the world uh here are just uh
a few
highlights take a look
[Music]
these are everywhere this is a cuban pay
phone
that enables you to make a call and get
your hair permed at the same time
the only problem is it will only call
that you just don't see this anywhere
else
whole row of just one product
vinoseco sweet wine and window let's see
we cannot film here i don't need to i
was just wondering if you had any uh
um i'm just vino secco el mundo
oh here it is
[Music]
love you
[Applause]
this is my stick are you going to do
that with me
i'll punish me with that stuff
oh why are you liking yeah
stop liking it no no stop you don't
understand my entire fantasy is a stern
woman i don't like you can i say you're
the best dressed soldier i've ever seen
in my life
yeah like a janet jackson backup dancer
it's incredible he looks amazing you're
in north korea i'm in north korea
i'm still in south korea oh
[Music]
congratulations
[Music]
those gentlemen right there are sheep
herders
and i'm disappointed because they're
dressed
like bouncers
[Music]
[Applause]
your natural speaking voice is driving
them that way
you're a great herder
[Music]
yes he gets me what is your name
david it was very nice to meet you
[Music]
or something if i'm done shooting maybe
later on i can come by
you know you don't believe me
does your family know that you meet
strangers on the street and invite you
up
to your house for coffee do they know
about that
i worry about you i don't want you doing
that because i could be
i could be crazy right look at me it
could be crazy
the male echidna um actually has
a four-pronged penis
[Laughter]
why um why not
she's good
[Music]
[Applause]
trump said you would pay i put these
huh no you can't no
oh donna i want to wear a ghana shirt
what do you think
another big deal here in ghana is having
a fantasy
coffin so this is someone who died of
type 2 diabetes
the great thing about this turkey coffin
is that
you get to be the stuffing
are you laughing because you like the
joke or just to be polite
oh the cough at the end oh it's not the
cough that carries you off
it's the coffin they carry you often
[Music]
put in my special request a tv so i can
watch myself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there are companies throughout japan
that provide
fake families for people who are lonely
i am back
in my hotel room in tokyo and i have a
family
this is incredible
could you guys like ramen
yes we do not me i like my men cooked
please tell them to laugh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i'm worried now that if i tell her um oh
i just came back from the doctor and i
only have a year to live
we're here to buy your country hi here
to buy your country
good evening i'm calling o'brien and i'm
bringing you the latest global report
for dreamland apagu our finning
rambi sela samarik illamasarit takatella
purit
isiganalurisi illamasurit ticatanic
veterina
is
when i'm walking around i like to yell
out random
italian things you know nagnolotti
you keep thinking it's offensive people
just think that i'm italian
tell them pumpkin spice latte
yeah no no no no
what i like to do is drive around here i
have very specific music that i like to
listen to
guess what i looked into it to play that
music
would cost us a lot of money i had the
band
make us up some music that doesn't cost
us anything
[Music]
you see this sounds very stereotypical
to me almost to the point of insulting
i brought some sound effects you want to
listen to those
but we can also uh have silence as well
if you wanted to just
uh listen to this
uh-oh oh the car stalled huh hold on
oh can you stop the car for a second
stop it yeah
just one other thing yeah
[Applause]
uh two quick things uh when i did the
weather
in greenland that went out that was the
weather report
for greenland that night and i walked
around the whole next day and people
were like what
what was that that was a mess
uh i really did run away on camera
because i thought
that was the only way out uh the other
thing i want to mention is i went to
armenia with my assistant sonam
obsession
and uh
i have to give sona a big shout out
she's been a big part of uh my life
these last 11 years
and uh she is uh not working with us at
the moment
because any day now she will be giving
birth to twins
so oh yeah
right there she is wait a minute
wait a minute
i uh i didn't know you were here
no
you told me you couldn't work but you
can come out here and check the show out
[Laughter]
we love you sona and we're so excited
for you and thank you for everything
you